Hey, Mik-Mik! Are you ready?
Get me down this second!
You asked for it!
All I want is a simple life.
You’re always unhappy.
I wanted you to wake up from your slumber!
Is that a baby grizzly? How did he get here?
It must’ve been misdelivered.
I suggest that we all help Carl...
No no, don’t say another word.
…deliver this baby grizzly.
Nooooooooo!!!
Lets go!
They’re waiting on a stork
to deliver a baby to this grizzly fool.
Someone needs to steal the baby.
That will show them not to mess with me.
How many of them are there?
A bear.
Is anyone hungry?
A hare.
Stop yelling at me, Mik-Mik.
It’s bad for your complexion.
A stork.
What’s wrong? Can’t catch up?
And some weird creature with black spots under its eyes.
I am the giant panda wizard.
Carl, what does your inner GPS say?
Route calculated.
It’s that way.
What’s going on? No no no!
The avalanche is catching up!
Hold my bear.
Saving the world always gives me a headache.
We’re going down!
Prepare for impact!
From now on I’m flying first class.
Follow me!
This is outrageous!
I thought you wanted an adventure.
Snow, winter.
No no, it’s just cold summer.
No, it’s not time for paw licking yet!